happy hugs watch - all I really do enjoy
what my patreon supporters go season
along me yes this is a patreon sponsored
review because yeah if you want to
ensure that I've watched something that
you think I might not get to otherwise
you could do that through the patreon
okay plug out of the way this is a Wow
depending on what version you see either
a two-part or three-part but other than
the ways in which the episodes are
divided up I don't think is altered
otherwise miniseries adaptation of Terry
Pratchett's Discworld novel the
hogfather so I had not seen this before
I have not read the hogfather I've only
read one Discworld book to date which
was fittingly enough another patreon
sponsored review that was the monstrous
regimen which I enjoyed quite a bit but
I'm not super familiar with Discworld I
know a bit about it I know there's a lot
of sort of recurring characters and
organizations and whatever but it's not
like a continuous narrative or anything
across all the books that are set down
so I didn't know a ton about this one I
could guess from some of the the images
I found just sort of looking up the
basis to be to be sure that I was
finding the version that the person
commissioned me to do I immediately saw
whoa okay so death is gonna be a major
character in this and yeah yeah he is
apparently that was actually quite a
thing in Discworld death death got a lot
of pages like as a character so oh boy
how does one explain this okay
Discworld is a world not dissimilar to
but very distinct from our own it posed
a lot of similarities but is very much
its own place with its own rules but to
give you an idea of like how big the
similarities can be at times the opening
narration literally says
we open on the eve of hogs watch an
annual celebration not dissimilar to
your Christmas I mean that's it this is
a bizarre fantasy Christmas movie is
what it is so hugs watch has in place of
either father Christmas or Santa Claus
the hog father who effectively does the
same thing
he comes down the chimney he leaves
presents for children who have left him
notes and treats in this case a pie
like a little meat pie and a glass of
sherry beats cocoa so you know that's
that is the idea of this holiday now the
premise of this story is that some
people I'm I'm not gonna try to explain
what that there's a lot I'm not gonna
try to explain about this thing but some
people go to the guild of assassins
because one of the qualities of
Discworld is that virtually everything
has a guild and there is a guild of
assassins and they contract the
assassins to kill the hogfather
and what then proceeds to happen over
the length of the story is the assassin
assigned to it a guy by the name so
spelled out his name is mr. teatime but
it's pronounced according to him mr. Tia
timing so he is going through what he's
going through do attempt to kill the
hogfather going through some very
unconventional means because it's a very
unconventional target at the same time
we are dealing with the character of
Susan who is a governess babysitter type
for some young children and also happens
to be the granddaughter of death as in
the Grim Reaper as in the physical
embodiment of death
you know big skeleton cloak side that
guy and death himself is wrapped up in
all of this because when the hog father
seems to disappear
heed for reasons that don't come become
clear until much later begins to take up
the slack and to do the hog father's job
because he feels that it is important
that the world not lose faith and belief
in him so that's sort of your general
outlined premise man this thing's weird
I mean that's kind of the nature of
Discworld stories but it's not just that
it's weird it's weird in a really casual
kind of deadpan way because so much this
is so strange it's ugly and it's strange
because it is familiar because it's
taking all these cues from you know the
world or history as we know it but it's
just like a little turned on its head
with no acknowledgement that any of this
is weird so you know the fact that the
Tooth Fairy is real ya know that's just
what is the case around here yeah
there's a there's basically a college of
wizards who are supposedly the greatest
thinkers in the world but really just
kind of sit around and and just potter
around all day and their solution when
somebody needs help is they go well
we've got all these potions why don't we
mix everything together and see what
happens
like greatest minds in the world Wow
okay but again nobody comments on it
that's just this world this is just how
it is when the little girl says that
there's a monster in the basement this
is gonna it's gonna eat her
that's literal and real and the
governess goes down and beats it up with
a poker and throws it out of the house
that's the world we're dealing with it's
very sweetly strange in a very
unassuming fashion and it is a lot of
fun it's quite enjoyable the cast is
very good the voice of death acted by
the name of Ian Richardson he does great
work as does his assistant Albert
Susan's really good the granddaughter
who I mentioned I was actually quite
taken by mr. tota
his he had the weirdest presence the
strangest voice and like oftentimes just
slapping a silly voice onto a character
I'm like that was dumb why'd you do that
but in this case it just it made him so
off-putting and hard to pin down that
was kind of perfect at least for me I I
read somewhere that he's actually
portrayed fairly differently from how he
was in the book in terms of attitude so
I can't speak to that but as a character
and I'm itself because like he there in
this castle and he sees a guy and goes
hi there my name is Tia timeI I will be
your worst nightmare this evening and
then he stabs a guy it it's oh so weird
I'm like ah if you have a drink to hand
take a sip every time I said the word
weird cuz I'm gonna say it a lot so if I
were and here's the thing the criticisms
that I might have about this thing I'm
not sure there's much that can be done
about them and what I mean by that is if
I were looking at this thing completely
in a vacuum and I didn't know it was
adapted from a novel then there are a
number of things that I would bring up
the pacing of revelations about the
story are very awkwardly placed in terms
of at what point we learn literally
anybody's motivation for doing nearly
anything it so it is a ways into the
story before we learn the motivation of
the people who hired the Assassin's
Guild why death is covering for the
hogfather you know why you know why
people are behaving the way they are why
we keep cutting back to the to the
Wizards at all they don't have an active
part in the story for a long time but
they keep showing up from an early point
on so those are the sorts of things I
would kind of take issue with if this
was created as a miniseries but knowing
it's an adaptation I can look at those
same things and go I bet that that plays
just fine on paper now this is something
that one of these days I'm gonna devote
a video to
but the a very weird thing happens when
a piece of fiction is very carefully
tailored to the medium it is originally
designed for and in the case of Terry
Pratchett he's writing for a novel and
he's he is designing his stories to work
best in novel chapter format although he
doesn't really do chapters does he as i
recall so forget the chapter thing but
like that's the format he's working with
and you can get away with things in a
novel in terms of flow and the pace of
information and you know just taking
some time to just show us something
that's a little vignette for this world
that doesn't work as well in a forwardly
propelled visual medium because one of
the big strengths of a book if you know
how to play to it is that people can
basically pause at any moment you can't
actually truly control the pacing at
which people take it in whereas in a
visual medium like film and television
you have complete control of that pacing
but that pacing can bite you in the butt
because it doesn't stop so things that
might be fun divergences in a novel
become pace killers on screen or at the
very least you know make for awkward
moments in terms of the overall flow of
the story because you can't stop it has
constant forward momentum even in a
slow-moving story because time doesn't
stop moving as the visuals go and there
are just things that you can write in a
book that when you put them in a paren a
perpetually forward moving medium like
film and television that they don't play
as well and I think a lot of the things
that I mentioned are kind of what's
going on here in addition the other
thing you lose is the writers voice and
I think that does impact this a bit I
would imagine it you know again not
having read hogfather specifically but
having read a Discworld book and having
read Good Omens which it was written in
even though Neil Gaiman worked on it
with him was written in his style much
more than Gaiman style the way in which
Pratchett constructs words reminds me
very much of Doug
Adams's and i have a feeling if i had
read the hogfather that i would have
similar criticisms to when i see visual
adaptations of adam's his work which is
that a big part of what is so great
about the book is the word choice it's
not what is being described it's how
it's being described and pratchet in the
one disk or book I've read definitely
had that going for him and that kind of
always suffers when translated to a
visual medium because something that in
its original on page form has fun
wordplay and neat comparisons in these
metaphors and like oh well it's kind of
like this but then not really at all and
I don't know why I got British with that
accent I apologies to all my UK viewers
but you know and but all that gets lost
when all you can do is just show the
thing and I have a feeling that some of
the other things that are a little weird
in terms of getting my feet under me for
how things are working in this world cuz
you know I don't know Discworld like the
back of my hand I have a feeling none of
that stuff would have been an issue in
reading the book because the narrative
way in which it things are described the
author's voice would have picked up the
slack there and then removing that again
makes the general progression a little
bit awkward I strongly suspect that this
miniseries is the kind of thing that I
will enjoy much more on a second watch
which do consider that a recommendation
I do plan to watch it again in the
future but the reason I say that is
because if you don't already know what's
going on it can it can take you a little
while to sort of get on the things
wavelength and now they get it and they
it's not like it took me to the very end
of the thing to get it about halfway
through I had my feet under me but now
that I get what it is I have a feeling I
will enjoy it much more on a second
viewing than I did on the first which
isn't to say I didn't enjoy the first
view I did but I could feel sort of the
way I was kind of being held at arm's
length by the limitations of a visual
medium which sounds weird in my head how
is a visual medium more limited well
when you're dealing with a wordsmith
like Pratchett nobody's visuals are
going to measure up to what he can do
with words that's not a knock on visuals
that's a praise of Pratchett
but it does mean you get a little bit of
a shift and a little bit of a oh that's
not quite working as well or as funny as
it did on the page anymore because of
what you lose in the trends in the
transition that said I am very glad that
they made the decision to do a
miniseries instead of trying to cram
this into a two-hour movie because then
oh my god I can't imagine it would have
worked at all so that helped minimize
the issues of the pacing of it but it is
such a bizarre weird take a shot world
that is just fun to be in it's so
familiar yet so alien at the same time
and everyone just acting like it's
perfectly normal because of course to
them it is but that just makes it like
huh
someday when I have time I do want to
read more Discworld books because the
the feel and the vibe of this is
terrific and the effects actually aren't
bad either considering this I think was
2007 made-for-tv I mean the the most
obvious thing is that deaths mouth
doesn't move
probably because trying to get an
animatronic synced up and working and
looking any good would have been too
much of a hassle not necessarily that
the effect itself would have been too
expensive but the amount of time that
would add to the shooting for how many
retakes you'd have to do every time the
animatronic doesn't behave itself that
probably made it unfeasible so that's
the kind of thing where it shows its
limited budget a little bit because you
know death is just this skeletal face
that doesn't move but again the voice is
great some of the locations are terrific
they they get a lot out of this this is
well put together I quite enjoyed this
and if you are looking for a new holiday
thing to add to your rotation and you
feel like you've seen every iteration
under the Sun of every Christmas Santa
story but you haven't seen this yet add
it to your plans this season seriously
the hogfather the miniseries you seen it
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments
let's talk about it stuff to do of
course patreon
it's about this video even happened and
my social media I've got a peel box if
you feel like sending me something for
the holidays I mean you know so there's
that there's links to my other socials
like subscribe the usual stuff go ahead
do it or don't you don't have to at the
end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]